Dr. Alan, se uma pessoa estiver correndo
o risco de infarto ou AVC e por acaso
beber dois copos de água sem saber, isso
pode evitar o evento? Não. Esse efeito é
apenas momentâneo. Po, vai ajudar, mas
não vai evitar se tiver com todas as
condições para um infarto. A pessoa
percebe que infartar ter AVC? Depende.
Tem pessoas que percebem, tem os
pródromos, né, do AVC e tem gente que
não percebe. Beber água apenas ameniza
os efeitos? Sim, só vai amenizar os
efeitos. O que que ela deve fazer para
evitar que o perigo retorne? Tá
lembrando que a hidratação adequada é
para prevenção a princípio, não é?
eficaz como intervenção para um evento
agudo. Tem estudo de Rava de falando
redução de 53% no risco de AVC para quem
está prevenindo, tomando água
consistentemente ao longo de vários
meses, não é para tomar na hora do
infarto, desculpa, do AVC, OK?
Obviamente que a hidratação vai diminuir
a viscosidade do sangue, vai ajudar um
pouco.